now to present the film editing award a
man who comes from the ranks of film
editors the brilliant young director
mark grobson that is
thank you paul
however i'm not a young director
but an old cutter
for the benefit of those who do not know
what a film editor is
he's the man who works at the side of
the director
assembling the film and putting it into
completed form
after many weeks
after cutting and sniffing
he's finally able to get the picture all
set
even even after the picture is a hit
he's the man in the lobby who mutters
i wish they would have let me have
another crack at it
now those nominated for tonight's award
in film editing
are
all the king's men a robert ross in
production
columbia robert parish and al clark
battleground metro golden mayor john
dunning
champion screenplays corporation united
artists harry gerstat
sans of iwo jima
republic richard l van enger
and the window rko radio
frederick newton
and the winner is harry gerstadt
so
thank you mark robeson and
congratulations harry gersted